schönen Ostermontag euch allen hier ist
Toni und ihr hört heute noch mal das
Osterspezial die großen Tatort
Deutschland Dokus
heute haben wir für euch die Folge der
Parkhaus Mord noch mal hochgeladen viel
Spaß
[Musik]
ich bin ein rechtskräftig verurteilter
so vor mal weg weil die halt der
Auffassung waren dass irgendeiner und am
besten ich eingesperrt werden soll für
den Ort an meiner Tante
Benedikt todt genannt Benze spricht da
über sich selbst 16 Jahre Knast sitzt er
in der JVA Stadelheim ab in diese
Episode von Tatort Deutschland machen
wir uns gemeinsam ein Bild davon ob bei
diesem aufsehenerregenden Fall am Ende
ein Unschuldiger hinter gitterwandelte
ich bin Sky du Mont und freue mich dass
ihr wieder dabei seid heute der Parkhaus
Mord
[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
[Musik]
mein Name ist Laura Germann ich arbeite
seit mehr als 10 Jahren für Bild und
habe natürlich viel mit mordprozessen
und auch anderen Fällen vor Gericht zu
tun die immer wahnsinnig spannend sind
und einer dieser Fälle ist der Fall von
Charlotte Böhringer
Reporterin Laura Gehrmann blättert durch
die archivierten Artikel der BILD am 15
Mai 2006 wird in München die als
Parkhaus Millionärin bezeichnete
Charlotte Böhringer eiskalt und mit 24
Hammerschlägen in ihrer Wohnung ermordet
der Verdacht der Ermittlungsbehörden
fällt auf den Neffen der Ermordeten auf
Benedikt tot
94 Tage dauerte Indizienprozess im
Anschluss wird Benedikt Tod wegen Mordes
verurteilt wegen der Schwere seiner Tat
wird er bis 2028 im Gefängnis bleiben
aber es gibt keine stichhaltigen Beweise
für seine Tat und bis heute betreut
Benedikt Benze tot seine Unschuld
die bild-reporterin ist vom deutschen
Rechtssystem überzeugt sie kann sich
nicht vorstellen dass ein Mensch auf
Basis von Indizien vielleicht sogar
unschuldig im Gefängnis sitzt es lässt
dir keine Ruhe
es ist Boarding für ihren Flug Berlin
München in München wird sie heute mit
denen am Prozessbeteiligten Menschen und
dem vermeintlichen Täter sprechen
Termin Nummer 1 für die Reporterin
München Innenstadt der Fachanwalt für
Strafrecht Peter Witting der verteidige
von Benze Tod der Rechtsanwalt arbeitet
seit 38 Jahren als Strafverteidiger
erregt sichtlich Umfassung
die Tat soll am 15 Mai 2006 begangen
worden sein in der Zeit um 18 19 Uhr 19
Uhr 30
in der Parkgarage angekommen sein er
muss nach Auffassung der
Ermittlungsbehörden Handschuhe getragen
haben er muss also präpariert gewesen
sein für einen Anschlag gleichsam gegen
seine Tante
er war bewaffnet mit einem unbekannten
Gegenstand er soll dann vor der
Eingangstür der Wohnung für Charlotte
Böhringer gewartet haben wohl wissen
dass sie gegen 19:30 Uhr üblicherweise
an einem Montag das war am Montag
in zum Stammtisch im Tal geht und
Charlotte bühringer war ein Begriff die
Wohnung zu verlassen so die These und
Benedikt tot hat dann 24 mal auf seine
Tante eingeschlagen bis sie am Ende
eines kleinen Flurs also vom Eingang
Richtung Wohnungs anderes zu liegen
kommt und dort verstirbt ich war und das
war immer mein meine Überzeugung soweit
man als Verteidiger überzeugt sein kann
und darf dass er nicht der Täter ist das
ist deutlich die bild-reporterin bedankt
sich und macht sich auf den Weg zum
Münchner Büro ihrer Zeitung dort
erwartet Sie Axel Petermann Petermann
war Polizeibeamter zuletzt
stellvertretender Leiter der
Mordkommission in Bremen mittlerweile
ist der bekannt als Bestsellerautor und
Profiler er wird in vielen Fällen als
Experte zu Rate gezogen die Eltern und
der Bruder von wenzitot haben sich an
ihn gewandt und den gebeten sich die
Akten des Falls noch einmal genauer
anzusehen ich bin der Auffassung dass
mir die Spuren einer Tat ganz ganz viel
über den Ablauf des Verbrechens
berichten
[Musik]
in der Nähe des Münchner Stadtzentrums
befindet sich das Isar Parkhaus das
ehemalige Böhringer Parkhaus das ist ein
schlichtes 5 geschossiges Nutzgebäude
unscheinbar alterslos aber in der
obersten Etage befindet sich noch heute
das Penthouse von Charlotte Böhringer
dem Mordopfer
Reporterinnen und Profiler betreten
gemeinsam die Wohnung
riesige Räume mit teilweise
kuppelförmigen Decken alles wird
herrschaftlich modern und vielleicht ein
wenig zu grell der Boden heller Marmor
und die vielen Fenster sorgen für
lichtdurchflutete Zimmer hier hat Frau
Böhringer zum Tatzeitpunkt als Single
gewohnt auf einem großen Tisch im
Wohnzimmer breiten Laura Gehrmann und
der Ex Polizist Tatort Fotos aus auf
einem ist die Frauenleiche in eine
riesigen Blutlache zu sehen also ich bin
zunächst erstmal davon ausgegangen dass
der Gutachter Recht hatte mit seiner
Angabe dass der Täter Handschuhe
getragen hatte und es fängt damit an das
gesagt wurde an der Eingangstür das kann
man hier auf diesem Foto ganz schön
sehen dass die Eingangstür hier oben ist
der Spion habe sich der Abdruck eines
Handschuhs gefunden und diese Abdruck
ist dann gesichert worden und das ist
jetzt hier das Bild des vom
vermeintlichen handschuhabdruck wenn man
sich das aber sehr genau anschaut dann
wird man sehen dass es doch recht
unregelmäßige Konturen sind manche sind
groß manche sind klein manche sind
langgezogen das war so der erste Zweifel
den ich hatte dass ich dachte mensch das
ist so unregelmäßig muss das überhaupt
kein Handschuh sein und dann wurde eine
zweite Spur für die eine Handschuhs
gehalten und dann habe ich mir die dann
angeguckt und vergrößert das hat mich
nicht überzeugt und deswegen habe ich
mir Sachverständige gesucht die eben
halt sich speziell mit solchen Spuren
auseinandersetzen und die haben dann
gesagt es ist ein Fingerabdruck besser
gesagt hier Frühstück wahrscheinlich der
Abdruck einer Hand Kante die Reporterin
hat nach wie wichtig ist es denn
feststellen ob
Video an hatte oder nicht also für das
Gericht war sehr sehr wichtig es
behauptete der Täter sei vorbereitet
gewesen und diese handschuhabdruck der
war letztendlich entscheidend dass er
die besondere Schwere der Schuld
zugesprochen bekam
kann das sein ein handschuhabdruck ist
die Grundlage für den längsten
Indizienprozess Münchens denn erst am 12
August 2008 wird das Urteil gegen wenze
tot gesprochen schuldig
Laura Gehrmann denkt nach die Aussagen
von Verteidiger Witting und Profiler
Petermann machen sie skeptisch die
Journalistin muss nun auch die andere
Seite hören sie besucht Rechtsanwalt Dr
Alexander Stevens um sich die Sichtweise
der Anklage schildern zu lassen Stevens
war zur Zeit des Prozesses
rechtsanwaltsanwärter bei der
Staatsanwaltschaft München mit dem
Parkhaus Mord kam ich den Berührung weil
ich zur Zeit der Verhandlung des
Parkhaus Mannes bei der
Staatsanwaltschaft meine Wahlstation
gemacht hatte natürlich kriegt man dann
auch das ein oder andere mit was man
vielleicht als Außenstehender nicht
mitbekommen hätte und damit war das
Interesse geweckt und Jahre später habe
ich einen Buch geschrieben bei dem es um
perfekte Morde gehen und deswegen habe
ich mich also diese diesen Fall
angenommen da sehr sehr tiefgreifend
recherchiert Urteil natürlich gelesen
auch Akten gelesen und mir dann ein
eigenes Bild gemacht und diese
Geschichte zu Papier gebracht auf die
Frage ob Benedikt Bentz schuldig ist
antwortet dr Stevens sehr bestimmt also
dass er zurecht hinter Gittern sitzt
davon bin ich zu 100 % definitiv
überzeugt doch damit alleine gibt sich
bild-reporterin Gehrmann nicht zufrieden
sie will wissen wie die Polizei beim
Verhör von Benze vorgegangen ist
zu dem Zeitpunkt hatte die Münchner
Mordkommission nachweislich sich
fortgebildet in den USA zu einer
gewissen Methode der sogenannten read
Methode und die macht also folgendes da
gibt es nicht nur den good cop und im
badkop diese Methode kennt man ja der
Eine schreit und ist dann für den
Beschuldigten für den Betroffenen dann
diese aggressive Person vor der Angst
hat und der das oder nette der Kumpel zu
dem man sich dann irgendwie hingezogen
fühlt und sich dann gegebenenfalls
öffnet so die Theorie bei der
read-methode ist es noch eine ganze Ecke
krasser und das einfach mal ganz kurz
übers Knie zu brechen versucht man da
den Leuten letztlich die Tat einzureden
indem man sie Möbel macht ja die werden
über stundenlang vernommen und denen
werden dann auch Dinge in Aussicht
gestellt die wenn Sie die Tat in
einräumen niemals zutreffen werden dann
werden Alternativen vorgegeben ja mit
gesagt ne du warst doch da und da aber
du hast ja doch eigentlich gar nichts
Schlechtes gedacht also das Messer in
die Hand genommen hast du wolltest doch
damit eigentlich nur irgendwie schnitzen
oder irgendwas also sie geben ihm
Alternativen vor die er dann aufnimmt
und wenn er die dann aufnimmt wissen Sie
sie haben den Täter und dann gehen sie
halt richtig hart mit dem ins Gefecht
dass man ihm letztlich ein Geständnis
das ist das das eigentliche Ziel der mit
Methode dann aus der Nase gezogen hätte
das gibt's ja eben nicht aber sah sich
wohl genötigt und ich finde das Wort
genötigt passt da auch ganz gut
Dinge zu sagen und sich dadurch in
eklatante Widersprüche zu verstricken
aus denen er nicht mehr rauskam
nach dieser Aussage zu den
Vernehmungsmethoden der Ermittler muss
die bild-reporterin mit der
entscheidenden Person sprechen sie wird
Benze treffen und begibt sich dafür auf
eine zweistündige Fahrt von München zur
JVA Straubing
mit der Erlaubnis für das Interview
trifft sie den Verurteilten alternd und
hager sitzt der Folie seine grau-blauen
Augen zeigen keine Wut aber auch keine
Freude
Laura Gehrmann setzt sich ihm gegenüber
und Benze beginnt zu erzählen was kurz
nach seiner Verhaftung geschah ich
dachte ja tatsächlich vielleicht in
einer halben Stunde lang werde ich
wieder entlassen es sind ja so viele
Widersprüche evoziert wurden
natürlich habe ich den bösen Willen
gesehen aber irgendwie habe ich mir
gedacht das kann eigentlich kann das
nicht sein weil das sind doch die guten
und also jeder Widerspruch der mir dann
vorgeworfen wurde das war das war
evoziert seitens der Mitleid entweder
haben sowas nicht kapiert oder sie
wollten was nicht kapieren und und und
dann gabs teamkreise wo ich dann
absichtlich verwirrt werden sollte zum
Beispiel irgendwie die die die die was
mir jetzt einfällt die Kombination
unseres Tresors und ich sollte jetzt
dann halt den Tresor dann öffnen oder
oder geistig öffnen und dann ging es
darum wie viel Umdrehungen dort wohin
stoppt zurück ich meine wen interessiert
es aber natürlich dann als schafhocke
dich da und konzentriere mich schneller
das muss schneller gehen schneller noch
mal von vorne schneller nein das war
nicht richtig noch mal was heißt hier
das war nicht richtig und sie sind
irgendwann einmal sind sie tatsächlich
so weitermachen soll damit und dann
hoffen sie okay jetzt ist es vorbei so
nein das stimmt nicht das sollte doch
bestimmt ich kann meine Tresor nicht ihr
und was tut es im übrigen zur Sache das
müsste sie schon uns überlassen was ihr
Fragen ja also das sind halt so
Kleinigkeiten und die Uhrzeit war schon
beschlossene Sache der dort verlässt
dieses Gebäude nie wieder also für die
war das klar nur bei mir war das dann
doch nicht klar na ja und es hat sich
dann halt immer in Wellen hoch geschaut
bis ich dann gesagt habe mit dem rede
ich nicht mehr also ich gehe jetzt also
ich war dann tatsächlich auch schon
aufgestanden ja genau in dem Moment
kommt so von der Seitentür eine rein und
äh also der war halt schon sehr sehr
viele der hat mich sehr freundschaftlich
und sehr sehr liebevoll
immer wieder beruhigt und alle sind
nervös und so weiter und ich soll auch
bitteschön ein bisschen nachsichtig sein
den Kollegen geben gegenüber der ist
auch übernächtig etc also wie gesagt
also das haben die natürlich schon sehr
geschickt gemacht dann sind Details
verschiedene Stränge miteinander
vermengt worden und es kam natürlich
kein eindeutiges Ergebnis dann raus und
ich habe versucht wieder die Stränge zu
entwickeln habe gesagt schauen Sie das
war an dem Tag das war an dem Tag kein
Wunder dass wir irgendwie wieder andere
Ergebnisse haben vielleicht sollte er
her reden zeigen
[Musik]
weil ich zwei Tage nicht geschlafen habe
aber ich versuche mich zu konzentrieren
nach dieser Prozedur wird dem jungen
Mann verkündet dass er nun eigentlich
erst festgenommen ist
es war nicht mehr so eine Überraschung
weil ich jetzt ja eigentlich schon
wissen müssen wie Stunden vorher
ich habe das bloß irgendwie nicht aus
mir rausgebracht
trotzdem Glauben zu schenken dass ich da
sitze um zu helfen immer ich war halt
auf psychisch dann doch in einer
Ausnahme Situation also zwei Tage kaum
geschlafen kaum gegessen
sind sie ganz erfahrenen Leuten
gegenüber dieser aufs Kreuz legen wollen
die Journalistin ist auf der Rückfahrt
nach München nachdenklich und im Zweifel
wie sie die so gegensätzlichen Aussagen
einordnen soll sie will den Fall noch
besser verstehen
dazu gehört es mehr über das Opfer zu
erfahren wie hat Charlotte Böhringer
gelebt wie war ihre Beziehung zu ihrem
Neffen Benze dafür trifft sie sich mit
Brigitte klein einer guten Freundin der
Ermordeten Geschäftsfrau
gemeinsam stehen sie vor der Pizzeria
Lago di Garda die sich direkt neben dem
Parkhaus befindet da ging unsere
Charlotte immerhin da war das Parkhaus
dann ist sie runter und vom Kochen hat
sie nicht viel gehalten also ab ins
Lager die Garda Böhringer
öfter zu Feierlichkeiten auch in ihrem
Penthouse eingeladen ein zwei Mal hat
sie das gemacht aber da war sie auch zu
nervös sie wollte das perfekt machen
dass sie hat dann lieber in die Kneipe
eingeladen das war ja angenehmer als bei
sich zu Hause okay aber die
Berichterstattung hatte das Mordopfer
Charlotte Böhringer auch als sehr
gesellig und trinkfreudig bezeichnet
genau also gut und gerne ein gebärcher
würde ich sagen sie sah sehr gut aus und
es wurde jetzt Haltung berichtet darüber
mit Fotos sind und wo ist die Bussi sie
hat dieses Leben sehr genossen denn
Benedikt haben wir öfter mal
kennengelernt er hat sie öfter begleitet
und er war auch ihr lieblingsnevel
später kam ja dann im Laufe der Zeit
dass das der Neffe verdächtigt wurde und
wir waren erst mal alle völlig
fassungslos natürlich gab es auch Leute
die gesagt haben der arme Kerl wurde von
ihr hin und her geschickt und muss die
Jura studieren und wollte das nicht und
die Freundin wurde nicht akzeptiert
möglicherweise hat sie ja auch auf dem
Geldhahn gesessen also die Spekulation
da haben doch einige angetreten die sie
auch kannten weil man befürchtet hat
dass auf seine Bedürfnisse und seine
Wünsche von ihrer Seite möglicherweise
zu wenig Rücksicht genommen wird die
Reporterin hört in den Aufnahmen aus der
JVA nach was Benze dazu gesagt hat hätte
er überhaupt einen Grund gehabt seine
Tante zu ermorden Komplex also meine
Tante war eine hochkomplexe Frau wenn
sie fröhlich war war sie vielleicht zu
fröhlich für die Begriffe andere Leute
wenn sie traurig war aber sie dann halt
auch gleich melancholisch wenn gemocht
hat hat sie geliebt und wenn sie halt
dann
nicht gemacht hat hat sie halt gehasst
alles in Ordnung und einschätzbar für
mich ich meine ich habe sie mein ganzes
Leben lang gekannt also von von
Kleinkindes bei Ihnen an also meine
Tante wird ja jetzt leider fast
durchgehen negativ dargestellt was ja
nicht so ist ich meine das ist halt dann
das was vielleicht hängen bleibt bei
denen die sie nicht bekannt haben also
zunächst war meine Tante eine sehr
liebende und großzügige Frau und sie hat
halt aber auch Ansprüche gestellt ja und
sie hat
wenn Ihre Vorstellungen nicht
erfüllt wurden auch kein Plattform und
genommen Benedikt nimmt sie in Schutz
vor den negativen Darstellungen in der
Presse die Reporterin vermutet Kalkül
will er betonen dass er gar keinen Grund
hatte so eine Tat zu begehen
Charlotte Böhringer war Erben und
Geschäftsfrau zu der das Böhringer
Parkhaus Sam Tankstelle und Werkstatt
gehört die Witwe hatte zurzeit der Tat
ihre beiden Neffen angestellt Benzer als
Assistent der Geschäftsführung und
seinen Bruder Mate als Schichtleiter und
den trifft die bild-reporterin in genau
dem Parkhaus über dem der Mord geschah
an dem Tag hatte ich ja Spätschicht
beginnt um 15:45 Uhr ich war kurz davor
da die Mitarbeiter der Frühschicht haben
gesagt dass sie meine Tante nicht
erreicht haben also herzlichen ganzen
Tag nicht gerührt und wir wussten nicht
wo sie ist oder warum sie nicht da ist
ich kann mich noch daran erinnern ich
habe es dann am Handy angerufen hier von
der Türkei und
habe auch das Klingeln auf der anderen
Seite gehört die Unruhe wurde wo er
immer größer später waren wir auch oben
auf dem Dach weil wir gedacht haben
vielleicht hat sie hinten bei der
Waschküche das Fenster offen gelassen
zum Lüften dass man vielleicht auch in
die Wohnung reinkommt
wann alle Fenster zu und da es war auch
nichts zu sehen ja ich war ja auch
perfekt mein Bruder hat sich übergeben
ich muss ja auch gar nicht ob es einen
Mord ist oder ein Unfall dass sie die
Treppe vielleicht runter gestürzt ist in
unzähligen Zeitungsartikeln die über die
abscheuliche Tat veröffentlicht wurden
waren immer wieder Zweifel an der Schuld
von benzodot geäußert worden ein
wichtiger Punkt für den Schuldspruch war
der Todeszeitpunkt
Profiler Axel Petermann misst traut der
korrekten Bestimmung der Todeszeit der
Mageninhalt ist eine Möglichkeit
einzuschätzen wann jemand gestorben ist
und das Gericht war ja davon überzeugt
dass die Rechtsmediziner mit ihren
Berechnungen zum Mageninhalt Recht
hatten indem sie meinen Charlotte
Böhringer sei gegen 18:15 Uhr getötet
worden wir sind hier weil Charlotte
Böhringer Köpfe ihren Bruder hier im
Lago dicada gewesen ist man hat in ihrem
Magen doch Hefte einer Speise gefunden
und die Menge hat man mit 100 Gramm
gemessen und diese Menge bedeutet dass
sie dreiviertel des ger bereits verdaut
hatte und ging davon aus dass es 400
Gramm Nudeln gewesen sein sollen die
bild-reporterin wirft ein das Charlotte
Böhringer eventuell weniger gegessen
haben könnte richtig Charlotte Böhringer
also hieß es sei eine sehr
körperbewusste Frau gewesen die auf ihre
Figur geachtet hat die
Appetitszügler Einnahmen also nochmal
zur Pizzeria Lago di Garda der Betreiber
ist bereit zwei unterschiedlich große
Portionen des nudelgerichts zu servieren
das Charlotte Böhringer als letzte
Mahlzeit zu sich genommen haben soll
Axel Petermann kommentiert die beiden
unterschiedlichen Portionen nun haben
wir zwei Portionen hier eine große eine
kleine das Gericht hat angenommen dass
die Portion so groß gewesen ist
entspricht das was Charlotte Böhringer
gegessen hat diese genau und das wäre zu
viel das wäre zu viel
und nie gegessen alleine und dann kam
nicht in Frage nein genau dann gehen wir
ja nicht in Frage also man muss sagen es
lässt sich überhaupt nicht feststellen
wann Charlotte Böhringer gestorben ist
und mein Fazit ist dass viele der vom
Gericht angeführten Indizien nicht
schlüssig sind und aus diesem Grunde
hätte Benedikt hat nie verurteilt werden
dürfen
die bild-reporterin sitzt wieder im Büro
von Verteidiger Witting abgeschlossen
hatten Sie denn das Gefühl dass der
sämtliche Spuren verfolgt wurden dass
die Ermittlungen weiche weitreichend
nein es ist von Anfang an nur einseitig
ermittelt worden nur gegen Benedikt tot
und zwar ab mindestens ab dem Zeitpunkt
seiner Festnahme am 16.05 abends um 19
Uhr
da waren die Ermittler sicher Sie haben
den richtigen und es ging nur um ihn und
nichts anderes
die Reporterin scrollt wieder durch ihre
Aufnahmen mit Benze wie hat er
eigentlich den Tag des Mordes erlebt es
war ein Montag also das müsste der
15.5.2016 gewesen sein
und ich war in der Früh
zu Hause geblieben
weil weil ich eine Grippe aus
ausgebrütet habe im Bett
ähm
also ich war den ganzen Tag nicht im
Geschäft an diesem Montag jedenfalls ist
meine Verlobte dann ähm gegen 5 ist sie
gegangen und ist dann abends gegen 22
Uhr oder
22:30 Uhr wieder heim gekommen und dann
kam der Dienstwagen ja Dienstag war dann
normaler Tag also ich meine ich war dann
auch schon
Hintern also ich war auf alle Fälle dann
ganz normal im Geschäft also ins Büro
gefahren als wir unsere Tante nicht
erreicht haben
und mein Bruder oder oder oder auch
unsere Mitarbeiter also also das das war
jetzt Schichtführer zum Beispiel an der
Kasse also der hat z.B auch irgendetwas
[Musik]
gebraucht und das war jetzt noch keinen
keinen Anlass für Hunde die Wahrheit so
etwas regelmäßig vorgekommen ist dass er
bei spontan weggefahren ist jetzt nicht
länger aber durchaus oder halt
vielleicht irgendeine längere Nacht
gehabt haben um die Uhrzeit einfach noch
nicht dran gehen möchte Punkt fertig ja
gut dann mach mal halt anders und
da war es tatsächlich schon
also später Nachmittag um mein Bruder
hat dann festgestellt an der Tür
horchend also das Handy angerufen hat
dass das Handy tatsächlich aus der aus
der Wohnung durchklingelt da war es
ruhig und da hat er das Handy klingeln
hören das war dann schon außergewöhnlich
und das war dann das war dann der
Hintergrund oder da die die Ursache
dafür dass wir gesagt haben sollen jetzt
müssen wir handeln
und weil ich einen Schlüssel keine
unmittelbaren Zugangsschlüssel zur
Wohnung gehabt habe einen einen der
Geschäftsführer gebeten vorbeizukommen
der den Schlüssel hatte und mit dem gehe
ich dann letztendlich um
kurz nach sieben dann in die Wohnung
gegangen
na ja es war auf alle Fälle
bemerkenswert hell also das ist ja dann
eingebrannt auf der Festplatte ähm
das sind ziemlich heller Raum der ja
auch kurz davor gestrichen wurde der
hell gestrichen wurde heller Marmor
Boden also also
meine Tante lag da in einer riesen
Blutlache und alles war voll mit Blut
ich bin tatsächlich äh jetzt noch nicht
davon ausgegangen dass sie tot sein
müsste also das erste mal irgendwie
scheiße die ganze Zeit irgendwie die
Treppen runter die Haut weil das war
halt auch das waren die im Schlachthaus
anders kann ich nicht sagen also
zumindest für meine Erfahrung für mich
war es halt extrem und oder es kann auch
sie ich weiß es nicht mehr genau
jedenfalls bin ich angestoßen worden von
von dem Geschäftsführer schau mal nach
dem Puls daran kann ich mich noch
erinnern und dann bin ich hin habe mich
hingekniet und ich bin aber nicht einmal
dazu gekommen dass ich da irgendwie nach
dem Impuls tatsächlich Suche weil als
ich angefasst habe habe ich gemerkt dass
es
unnatürlich kalt steif
ist nicht nicht wie Plastik also es ist
also da hat auch offensichtlich das
Leben gefehlt es bleibt am Ende nur eine
Frage die nach dem Motiv der
Staatsanwalt gibt der Reporterin bei
ihrem Besuch zur Protokoll er hat ein
Motiv das erstklassiger gar nicht sein
könnte die Problematik dass seine Tante
ihn regelrecht geschafft hatte er war
nicht mehr der stellvertretende
Geschäftsführer oder Assistent der
Geschäftsführung nein es gab jetzt einen
neuen man hat ihm sogar den Schlüssel
weggenommen in eine größere Degradierung
gibt es ja gar nicht aber und jetzt
kommt der der very big point
geistesort hatte über Jahre hinweg
behauptet Jura zu studieren und nicht
nur das sondern auch ein juraexamen
abgelegt zu haben er hatte sogar ein
Weißwurstfrühstück ausgerichtet um das
ganze zu feiern das alles hat nicht
gestimmt es gab so ein Jurastudium das
hat er aber abgebrochen das war aber
eiserne Bedingungen der Tante für ihn
irgendwann mal die Geschicke dieser Park
dieses Parkhauses leiten zu dürfen das
haben sehr sehr viele Zeugen genauso
ausgesagt da haben wir noch einen Streit
der sehr unmittelbar vor der Tat
stattgefunden haben soll den wenn sie
dort aber zunächst in seiner Vernehmung
verschweigt und dann aber auch in einer
weiteren Vernehmung viel weiter
vordatiert auch das ist schon sehr
merkwürdig warum tut er das ja warum
spricht da nicht da die Wahrheit worum
ging es bei dem Streit
ja bei dem Streit ging es wohl um
irgendwas profanes mit den Reifen dass
sie nicht richtig aufgeräumt waren wie
auch immer aber die Tante auch
sekundärisch wohl hat ihn da also sehr
zu minder gemacht und auch so zumindest
nach dem Feststellungen des
Gerichtsurteils da das Rufes bewiesen
und gesagt er solle nie wieder kommen
also ein solches Motiv Bündel gleich
findet man selten und dann natürlich
die Tatsache dass da ein millionenerde
auf ihn warten würde wir reden ja hier
nicht von Kleinigkeiten und alle seine
Probleme und Sorgen wenn mit einem Male
mit dem Tod der Tante weg gewesen ich
habe keine Zweifel das ist ganz Import
war hat benzi gelogen war seine Tat
immer [__] der Wut auf seine Tante
hatte Charlotte Böhringer von dem Lügen
Gespinst ihres lieblingsneffen gewusst
der Bruder des verurteilten Mörders hat
dazu eine ganz eigene Meinung ganz klar
Herr ich bin ja auch hier gewesen und
also ich hätte ja nicht Car fahren
müssen und und wie alles drumrum
konstruiert wurde Zeitfenster ich war ja
vor Ort ich war ja Luftlinie hier fünf
Stockwerke oder vier Stockwerke tiefer
da hätten sie mich genauso rausnehmen
können wahrscheinlich haben sie halt
dann gesagt ach ja da hat es einen
Streit gegeben wird eingelagert und
Reifen und dann haben sie dann gesagt oh
das ist äh das ist elementar die haben
sich gestritten in der Familie und dann
haben die natürlich die in ihrem
Kommissar Mord Handbuch auf Seite 28
Jahre Familienangehöriger ist vorbei
und dann wird alles dann gegeben mein
Bruder hat ja auch gesagt dass er nicht
mehr studiert und das ist unsere Tante
gewusst hat das ist auch ein Prozess
geklärt worden ich meine die besten
Freundinnen und der Steuerberater haben
ja auch ausgesagt dass er nicht studiert
hat und im Urteil steht drinnen schaut
doch die Bürger als bis zuletzt davon
ausgegangen hätte sein Studium
erfolgreich beendet da sagt der zeige
das und im Unterschied was anderes drin
Boarding Flug München Hamburg
Laura Germann reicht das Gehörte nicht
um sich ein abschließendes Gesamtbild zu
machen ich bin hier in Hamburg
verabredet mit dem Rechtsanwalt Gerhard
Scharte der ist dafür zuständig in dem
Fall dass wieder Aufnahmeverfahren ins
Rollen zu bringen der Straße ist ein
Spezialist für solche aussichtslose
Fälle und hat als einer der wenigen
überhaupt in der deutschen
Rechtsgeschichte ist schon ein paar mal
geschafft schon wieder Aufnahmeverfahren
erfolgreich durchzusetzen hallo schönen
guten Tag hallo was ist so ungewöhnlich
an dem Fall ja ist deshalb schon ich
will nicht sagen ungewöhnlich wohl aber
zeichnet er sich dadurch aus dass er
wirklich
Beweise ins Feld führt also das Urteil
Indizien zusammenstellt die alle jeder
für sich
nicht unbedingt tragfähig werden
insgesamt aber meinte damals das Gericht
in der Gesamtschau es würde das
ausreichend um klar zu erklären dass
bental top der Täter ist und in der
Regel sind bei diesen Kapitalverbrechen
die Indizien zumindest an ein oder zwei
Punkten immer doch von großer
Eindeutigkeit das ist bei diesem Fall
nicht also jedes Indiz was hier auf
bensche trotz hinweisen soll ist für
sich genommen relativ neutral das
spricht auch das Gericht selber an in
dem schriftlichen notarztkunden aber zum
Schluss heißt es dann doch in der
Gesamtschau seines eindeutig und
Menschen dort sei der Täter
warum sollte der Fall ihrer Meinung nach
wieder aufgerollt werden
ich hatte mich hierbei konzentriert auf
zwei Spuren die in der Gesamtschau der
Indizien von großer Bedeutung sein
sollen nämlich zwei DNA-Spuren an einem
Briefumschlag in dem sich das Testament
befand und des Weiteren eine Spur
der Rückseite der Jacke die Frau
Möhringer an dem Tage getragen hat
diese beiden Spuren sind nicht eindeutig
Menschen tot zuzuordnen es gibt mehrere
spurengeber vor allen Dingen jetzt aus
der Familie die auch in Betracht kommen
diese Spuren müssen auch nicht am Tag
Tage angebracht worden sein insgesamt
plädiere ich in dem Teil meines wieder
Aufnahmeantrages dafür dass diese Spuren
auch nicht hätten verwertet werden
dürfen das führt Laura Germann zu ihrer
abschließenden Frage
ihrer Meinung nach denn zurecht hinter
Gittern
also das kann ich relativ eindeutig
beantworten also wenn schon gehört dort
nicht hin die Reporterin fliegt zurück
nach Berlin sie muss weiter
recherchieren erst dann wird es in ihrem
Kopf Ruhe geben wenn dieser Mann seit 16
Jahren unschuldig im Gefängnis sitzt
muss etwas getan werden ist der schuldig
dann können die Angehörigen des Opfers
und auch das vermeintlichen Täters damit
abschließen und die Erinnerung an
Charlotte Böhringer Ruhe vor weiteren
Spekulationen finden
schön dass ihr in dieser Folge von
Tatort Deutschland dabei wart ich hoffe
wir hören uns bald wieder euer Sky Demo
[Musik]
ich bin von Süd nach Nord gereist habe
Weggefährten von dem Benedikt getroffen
habe seine Anwälte getroffen aber auch
Menschen die damals in der
Staatsanwaltschaft tätig waren und habe
wahnsinnig viele Eindrücke gesammelt
[Musik]
die Frage die sich mir stellt ist
natürlich nicht ist ja schuldig oder ist
ja nicht schuldig weil die werden wir
nie beantworten können die werde ich
auch nie beantworten können die Frage
ist das Urteil so gerecht wie es gefällt
wurde und hätte es jemand so gefällt
werden dürfen ist natürlich eine andere
und da kann ich jetzt nach meinem
Recherchen und nach meinen Gesprächen
sagen dass es auf jeden Fall Zweifel
daran gibt waren die Indizien wirklich
ausreichend um den verschuldig zu
befinden und da kann man auf jeden Fall
Zweifel dran haben und auch sagen dass
die Indizien nicht so eindeutig waren
dass das eine Grundlage dafür war ihn so
lange hinterher geht dann zu packen
Tatort Deutschland ist eine Produktion
aus den Wakeboard Studios Projektleitung
Simone terbrak Produktion Fabian
Schaeffler Drehbuch Dieter Auras
Bildredaktion Laura Gehrmann und Stefan
netzelband